talk to me about this thing man is is
planting the seed of the holidays gonna
make this necessary watching for the
rest of the holidays to come i hope so
it's uh it's fun we've always wanted to
do a story we had a little bit in iron
man 3 that was uh that was our christmas
story nobody really looks at it we sort
of consider that a christmas movie but
this on a bashfully is a holiday story
and uh and i love the idea of it being a
perennial that people can check out uh
every holiday season
this is the first christmas we've had
together
in years
i love you guys
i'm making up for some lost time and i
love that it's debuting just before
thanksgiving it concludes just before
christmas and
for the first time you get a title uh
uh avenger on disney plus which is great
and jeremy renner of course is the best
and and he's the reason to do it and and
thankfully haley wanted to work with him
so we got her to play kate bishop and
it's that pairing that i think is going
to make for a very happy holiday this is
too
jeremy's character sort of takes haley
under his wing a little bit looking back
at your career was there somebody early
on that was established that maybe
helped you along help show you the ropes
a little bit well there were lots of
people sure that's a great question lots
of people i was very lucky to work with
a lot of people avi rod who hired me at
marvel
laura ziskin who produced the the
spider-man movies early on uh of course
lauren schuler donner who brought me
into this business
and amy pascal who i now work with on
the spidey movie so i'm very lucky to
have a lot of mentors over my career you
had the good the good folks in your
corner yeah
um talk to you about the holidays real
quick you got holidays coming up you
have any traditions you look forward to
any new traditions you're adding
well i think we're trying to hopefully
we can get back to some of our old
traditions this year that we couldn't do
obviously and being with family and then
having family come and travel together
safely and be together
is what i'm most looking forward to